c'est avec wohlen fera bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline et donc à la une
de la presse le début de cette campagne
pour le second tour de la présidentielle
en france qui opposera faut-il le
rappeler le dimanche 24 emmanuel macron
à face à la nécessité de rassembler pour
le second tour le président sortant est
la candidate du rassemblement national
on l'a vu cherche désormais à élargir
leur base électorale aux risques de
troubles et leurs soutiens traditionnels
prévient le figaro en déplacement dans
le nord de la france sur les terres de
sa rivale emmanuel macron est allé au
charbon et libération et ironise sur son
approche un peu gauche de l'électorat
populaire qu'il tente de convaincre en
se disant prêt à discuter et
éventuellement du rythme et des bornes
de sa réforme des retraites qui pourrait
soumettre à un référendum
marine le pen elle on l'a vu également
été dans l'yonne à un département rural
qui lui a été très favorable et où elle
a proposé de son côté une tva à zéro
pour cent sur 100 produits alimentaires
pour aider au pouvoir d'achat une
posture ou plutôt une imposture sociale
d'après l'humanité qui assure que la
patronne du à rennes cherche à berné les
électeurs pas sûr que tout cela suffise
à convaincre les abstentionnistes et les
soutiens de jean luc mélenchon présenté
ce matin par le parisien aujourd'hui en
france comme les arbitres de ce second
tour des électeurs en proie à de gros et
adam et qui s'interrogent dans le
dessein de coco pour libération comment
faire barrage à le pen s'en passer pour
des pros mâcon telle est la question de
la saison au second tour de la série en
thérapie série à succès ici en france où
on suit effectivement un psy et ses
patients la stratégie de rassemblement
des deux candidats hélène qui également
décrypté dans la presse étrangère mais
le rien le jour voit se dessiner un
entre-deux tours dominé par des thèmes
de gauche entre un président qui se dit
au centre et sa rivale d'extrême droite
qui a réussi sa dédiabolisation en
trouvant plus à droite qu'elle entendait
eric zemmour le journal évoque un champ
de ruines politique et une tripoli za
sion de la politique française entre le
rn en marche et la france insoumise lié
à l'écrasement des partis traditionnels
provoqué par le vote utile de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique aussi on scrute de
très près l'ascension de marine le pen
et son éventuelle victoire est présenté
par le washington post comme un énorme
coup de pouce pour vladimir poutine le
quotidien américain qui rappelle la
visite de la candidate à moscou en 2017
et le financement de son parti en 2014
par une banque russe souligne également
son hostilité de longue date envers le
temps plus globalement le journal
s'inquiète de façon dont plus globale de
lecture en croissante des français vers
les populistes de tous bords un
phénomène qu'il attribue en partie à
l'attitude distante et technocratique je
cite des manuels macron donc t-il que
considère toutefois qu'il aurait fait du
bon travail notamment en matière de
lutte contre le chômage le washington
post pauline qui en arrivent à la
conclusion que le président sortant doit
se donner à fond dans le combat
électoral pour le bien de la france et
pour le bien du centre vital de l'europe
emmanuel macron à lille le temps et
marine le pen alliés putative de
vladimir poutine à voir aussi dans ce
dessein de brian adcock pour des
diplômes donne qui les montrent un se
disputant le drapeau français risquent
de le déchirer vladimir poutine hélène
accusé qu'on voit là sur ce dessin
accusé par le quotidien britannique dit
aïe de déporter des milliers
d'ukrainiens vers des régions reculées
de la fédération de russie le journal
fait état d'un décret publié sur un site
du kremlin prouvant selon lui que le
gouvernement russe aurait ordonné le
mois dernier le déplacement de près de
cent mille personnes des zones de guerre
en ukraine vers des régions telles que
la sibérie le caucase du nord l'extrême
orient et même le cercle polaire
arctique parmi les destinations citer
les républiques très militarisée de
tchétchénie d'ingouchie et du daghestan
et le blast de sakhaline qui se trouve
en extrême orient à la une également
l'élection hier au pakistan d'un nouveau
premier ministre après la chute du mur
amrane renversé par une motion de
censure une première dans le pays de
l'élection de shahbaz sharif sauf par
l'assemblée nationale fait la une de
pakistanais qui précise que le nouveau
chef du gouvernement est le frère de
nawaz sharif qui a été trois fois
premier ministre avant d'être destitué
en 2010 être pour corruption le
quotidien rapporte que chez base sharif
a immédiatement annoncé une hausse du
salaire minimum et des retraites un
geste pour lutter contre la flambée des
prix des matières premières mais aussi
pour désamorcer la colère provoquée par
son élection pas reçus par le journal
comme une nouvelle manifestation du
pouvoir dont disposerait une poignée de
familles pakistanaises pour manoeuvrer
je cite et manipuler un système
démocratique
en réalité fictifs ce sentiment a
d'ailleurs partagé par le 'financial
times' qui voit dans cette élection le
retour du pakistan et des vieilles
dynasties politiques pakistanaises les
sharif et les buts o qui était rival
acharné dans le passeur mais qui ouvre
finalement uni leurs forces contre
l'ancien super star du cricket imran
rade on ne se quittent pas là dessus on
a évoqué ici les soucis divers et variés
de la chanteuse britney spears ses
déboires avec son père et sa bataille
judiciaire qui avaient finalement abouti
en novembre dernier à la levée de la
tutelle qui lui avait imposée pendant 13
ans et bien sachez pauline que britney
qui enfin pu reprendre le contrôle de sa
vie est enceinte de son troisième enfant
leur papa et son coach sportif et la
star a tenu à annoncer elle même la
bonne nouvelle sur les réseaux sociaux
je les cite j'ai perdu tellement de
poids pour faire mon voyage à maui pour
finalement le reprendre je me suis dit
bon sang qu'est-il arrivé à l'estomac
mon mari m'a dit mais non tu es enceinte
de nourriture petit idiote
comme c'est mignon pharmacie c'est son
mari qui lui dit en plus merci beaucoup
et l'aisne à tout à l'heure